cellule de crise effectifs
supplémentaires report des municipales
pour faire face à une épidémie de
coronavirus exponentielle en guyane la
ministre d outre mer met les bouchées
doubles des renforts de la sécurité
civile sont arrivés ce mercredi pour
monter un hôpital de campagne ont limité
de l'hôpital de campagne de la sécurité
civile exprime les comprend varie de
médecine générale un bloc opératoire
envoûtante l'expriment sera avec une
grammaire de 42 personnes dans 27
soignants capers logisticiens donc j'y
arrivais contre quatre amis grandes
marques et 3 vendredi
elle sera déployée pour accueillir des
patients nord pour vivre la menace d'un
reconfirme envisagée dimanche par les
services du premier ministre dit vise
une population déjà astreinte à des
mesures plus strictes qu'en métropole
couvre-feu fermeture des commerces dès
18h et injonctions de rester chez soi le
week end les habitants eux réclament
plus de moyens
le message principal c'est que pour
pital de campagne oui mais pas n'importe
lequel et par n'importe quel prix
et donc aujourd'hui ça nous étonne de ne
pas entendre parler de moyens
supplémentaires en réanimation au
pouvoir traiter les cas positifs non
c'est de ça dont on a besoin
l'hôpital est malade on vienne depuis
des années depuis des années en de
moyens depuis des années on a pas hélas
aujourd'hui en fait l'état fait le cadre
déchets en nous disant qu'ils vont
installer vainqueur 20 lits pour traiter
des noms d'origine finances à dire qu'en
fait on va pouvoir faire ce qu'on devait
faire depuis les années et des années
mais nous ce qu'on veut c'est augmenter
la capacité traitement des copines
problème en guyane les hôpitaux sont
saturés selon le syndicat ut g santé
interrogé par nos confrères de guyane
1ère en mars dernier c'est surtout le
désoeuvrement des services de
réanimation qui inquiète
en temps normal moins de quatre lits
pour cent mille personnes
quand l'hexagone en compte le double
alors à l'hôpital de cayenne il a fallu
se réorganiser se tourner vers le privé
ou vers les antilles
nous sommes en jeu ont de gagner des
places dans l'établissement grâce à un
très bon travail avec la clinique près
de cayenne qui a ouvert les capacités
supplémentaires en nécessaire ce qui a
permis de dégager des places d'aval pour
nos patients qui étaient hospitalisés
notamment en chirurgie par exemple dans
certains secteurs de médecine grâce à
ses capacités qui ont été libérés nous
avons pu augmenter les possibilités d
admission en service qu'ovide
procéderont quand cela est possible
un certain nombre d'évacuations center
de passion réac au vide notamment ça a
été placé lundi jo qui sont
transportables c'est à dire qu'ils
peuvent supporter un vol de 12 heures
verre
les antilles il y a deux semaines ce
territoire de trois cent mille habitants
ne comptait que 500 cas on en compte
désormais plus de 2500 en cause la
proximité avec le nord du brésil
deuxième pays le plus touché au monde
avec plus d'un million de personnes
atteintes du coc vide 19 seul remède
proposé par la ministre d outre-mer un
plan d'accompagnement pour venir en aide
au brésil mais aucune annonce sur le
contrôle de la frontière
franco-brésilienne longue de plus de 700
km est donc très perméable la deuxième
région de france en terme de superficie
n'a jamais semblé aussi proche d'un
rebond finement